preheat the oven to give an output flux  density in the infrared regime of seven  yokto nano maggies  then make sure to grease and line two  6.5 atto parsec sandwich tins  break four eggs that's eggs not eggs  into a large mixing bowl then mix in 126  yota electron volts per speed of light  squared of both sugar and flour with two  barn mega parsecs of baking powder and  0.006 hubble barns of butter  divide the mixture evenly between the  two tins and bake the cakes on the  middle shelf of the oven for three femto  hubble times  sandwich together with jam once cool and  sprinkle over some caster sugar for  decoration and there you have it a  physics inspired victoria sponge cake  [Music]